These days, we hear a lot about data.
We know that our increasingly connected, and
digital world, is producing an abundance of
data.
Data alone, might not be that exciting.
But what it can enable, and the answers it
can provide, are important.
Data is now vital to our organizations.
To our society, and ultimately to each of
us.
No matter who you are, you're either producing
it, consuming it, or leveraging it.
To realize the clear benefits of data, we
need good quality data.
We need data that is accurate, managed, and
properly maintained.
We need to know where data is, who owns it,
whether it's kept current, and how to store
it properly for later use.
We also need the tools, and skills to work
with this data.
If we do these things right, the value of
all this data will increase, and be much more
useful in the years ahead.
It's gonna help us solve some of the most
intractable challenges we face.
When we handle sensitive data, what are the
regulatory and legal requirements?
Using data to inform our organizational decision-making
is called data management or information management.
To some degree, all organizations take advantage
of data management.
However, we must ask ourselves if we understand
and manage our data correctly, and if we are
getting the most value from it.
Every organization falls somewhere along a
continuum where weak data management is on
one end and high-performance data management
is on the other.
Where your data management performance falls
is in how well you govern the management of
data.
In trying to achieve high performance in managing
our organizational data, we must ask whether
there are agreed policies and processes, accountabilities,
formal decision structures, and enforcement
rules in that management.
The implementation of these types of qualities
is called data governance.
At a high level we'll define data governance
as data that is managed well.
This definition also helps us to clarify that
data management and data governance are not
the same thing.
Managing data is concerned with the use of
data to make good business decisions and ultimately
run organizations.
Data governance is concerned with the degree
to which we use disciplined behavior across
our entire organization in how we manage that
data.
It's an important distinction.
So, what's the bottom line?
Most organizations manage data, but far fewer
govern those management techniques well.
What are the main principles of data governance.
By principles, we mean the foundational concepts
of data governance.
They are transparency, accountability and
standardization.
Let's begin with the principle of transparency.
As the word suggests, in transparency, everyone
within an organization and those who interact
with the organization from the outside should
be able to clearly understand and be advised
in a timely manner of the processes and impacts
of data governance.
Transparency is essential to avoid surprises,
to gain buy-in from all those impacted people
and to build trust in the organization.
Transparency should include being clear on
why things are being done and the value of
those actions.
Data governance is a positive topic and that
means we want to be open and clear about it
throughout the life cycle of data management.
As an example, an organization should have
an information security policy that clearly
states what kind of data must never be store
or displayed on a public website.
This could include data on employees' birth
dates or home addresses.
The second principle is accountability which
encompasses the responsibilities of anyone
who has a role to play regarding data in an
organization.
If a person has a role to play in data governance,
it should be fully described, understood and
agreed upon by all involved parties.
Within a mature data governance environment,
we will hold people accountable for taking
specific actions at specific times.
As an example, if your role requires you to
disclose what stocks you hold and to enter
that data by a certain date, not adhering
to this requirement could result in termination
of your employment.
The third principle is standardization.
With standardization of data, we are concerned
with such things as how data is labeled, described
and categorized.
An example of data standardization is how
we might handle designations in an organization.
When we capture California, is our standard
to use CA or to spell out the entire state
name.
This can be a really big deal, why?
For one thing, if you wanted to do a search
for all data that includes information in
California, a lack of a standard will result
in incomplete results.
That is, if you search for CA only, you may
not get the results for the full word California.
Done right, standardization solves many challenges.
Standardization improves quality of data,
makes it more usable across systems and, subsequently,
makes it more valuable.
What all these core data governance principles
have in common is that they support data quality
which is a central goal of data governance.